大家好,
我是Jam,
這裡是AI Notebook,
你拿起手機打開相簿,
在搜尋框裡打海邊的日落,
幾張照片就跳了出來,
可是你從來沒有幫這些照片打過任何標籤,
也沒有寫過一個字,
手機憑什麼知道,
那幾張就是海邊的日落,
今天我要帶你看懂背後那個負責懂意思的零件,
它叫Embedding,
你每一次搜尋,
每一次收到推薦,
每一次AI幫你查資料,
它都在裡面,
而這整件事的起點,
是一位語言學家在1957年寫下的一句話,
我們先把這件事講清楚,
你的相簿裡可能有2萬張照片
你沒有幫任何一張寫過說明
沒有分過類
甚至有一半你早就忘記自己拍過
可是你在搜尋框打幾個字
機器就能撈出對的那幾張
這件事在十幾年前是做不到的
那時候的搜尋靠的是比對字面
你的檔案名稱裡有沒有這幾個字
有就找得到
沒有就找不到
而你那張照片的檔名叫IMG4527
它跟海邊的日落
一個字都沒有重疊
所以真正奇怪的地方
不是搜尋變快了
而是機器不知道從哪一天開始
好像真的知道海邊的日落
是什麼意思了
他到底怎麼知道的
答案不是他讀懂了中文
而是有人想到一個很怪的辦法
把意思這件事
變成了數字
這個辦法叫embedding
中文常常翻成嵌入
不過你先不用管這個名字
你只要記住他做的事情
就是把一段文字變成一串數字
舉個例子
你給他貓這個字
他吐回來的是一排小數
可能是三百個數字排成一列
這排數字有一個更好懂的講法
它就是這個詞在一張地圖上的座標
你想想我們平常怎麼描述一個地點
精度多少 維度多少
兩個數字就把一座城市釘在地圖上了
Embedding做的是同一件事
只是它的地圖不是兩個方向
而是300個方向
我們把這些方向叫做維度
維度你就想成地圖上的座標軸
兩個軸畫出平面地圖
300個軸畫出來的
是一張我們看不到
但電腦算得動的地圖
這張地圖只有一條規矩
意思越接近的東西
就位置就排得越近
貓跟狗會住在隔壁
貓跟沒積分會住在地圖的兩端
這排數字在工程上的名字叫向量
你把它當成一個座標就好
你可能會想
把字變成數字有什麼了不起
了不起的地方在於
電腦本來就只會算數
它不會讀書
你只要判斷怎麼退貨跟翻評流程
是不是同一件事
它做不到
因為這兩句話一個字都對不上
可是如果這兩句話都變成了座標
問題就換了一個樣子
要問的是這兩句話意思一樣嗎
現在只要問這兩個點離得近不近
前面那個問題需要理解力
後面那個問題只需要減法
這就是embedding真正解決的事情
它把一個機器做不到的問題
換成一個機器做得飛快的問題
從此以後
搜尋不再是找字
推薦也不再是猜你喜歡什麼
是找出跟你位置最近的那些人在聽什麼歌
你手機相簿那次搜尋
答案也在這裡
照片跟你打的那幾個字被放進了同一張地圖
機器只是算了一下誰離誰最近
這張地圖就是這支影片接下來要講的全部
我們要理解這張地圖有多不容易
就得先回到還沒有地圖的年代
最早的做法簡單到有點好笑
工程師先做一本字典
把出現過的詞全部編好
第一個詞編一號
第二個詞編二號
一路編到五萬
然後每個詞用一根很長的柱子表示
表示 柱子上有五萬格
只有屬於自己的那一格 填上一
其他四萬九千九百九十九格
全部是零 這個做法有個名字叫
One Heart 意思是隻有一格是熱的
它有一個致命的問題 你去量
任何兩個詞之間的距離
答案永遠一樣 貓跟狗的距離
等於貓跟沒積分的距離
也等於貓跟星期三的距離
在這個世界裡 每一個詞都
孤零零站在自己那一格上
跟其他所有詞的遠近完全相同
這不是一張地圖 這是一片沙漠 每一個點
每個點跟每個點都等句
你走到哪裡都沒有方向感
在這片沙漠裡
人們還是做出了能用的東西
最有名的一招叫磁帶
英文是Bag of Words
說法就像把一整篇文章倒進一個袋子搖一搖
不管順序
指數每個詞出現幾次
拿著郵件過濾就靠這招活了很多年
一封信裡中獎跟匯款出現太多詞
機器根本不用懂意思
數數字就能攔下來
後來有人再加一層聰明
1972年
劍橋大學一位叫Karen Spark-Jones的研究者提出一個想法
一個詞越少見
他越能代表這篇文章在講什麼
的這個字到處都有
所以他什麼都沒說
那現體很少出現
一出現就幾乎決定了主題
這一招叫TFIDF
到今天的搜尋引擎裡都還在用
但你有沒有發現
這些方法從頭到尾都在做同一件事
他們在數字
不是在懂詞
沙漠裡的小聰明在多
沙漠還是沙漠
轉機不是來自工程師
而是來自一位
從來沒碰過電腦的語言學家
1957年
英國人John Rupert Furse
在一篇論文裡寫下一句話
後來被引用了無數次
他說你要認識一個詞
就看它都跟哪些詞待在一起
這句話白話一點講就是
你不用查字典也能猜出一個生字的意思
只要看它前後都跟誰出現
有人跟你說他昨天喝了一整杯馬代茶
你就算沒聽過這個東西
也知道它大概是一種飲料
因為喝跟一整杯這兩個鄰居
已經把答案寫出來了
這個想法在語言學裡叫做分佈假說
1954年的Zedek Harris
也寫過更正式的版本
你注意一下時間
這句話比第一臺跑了這種神經網路的電腦還要老
而接下來60幾年
整個AI領域做的事情
某種程度上就是把這句話翻譯成數學
把那句話變成數學的第一次認真嘗試
發生在1990年
一群研究者做了一張巨大的表格
買的是每一個詞
值的是每一份文件
格子裡填的是這個詞
在這份文件出現幾次
這張表格大的離譜
而且幾乎全是空的
他們用一套線性代數的手法
把這張幾萬欄的表格
硬壓成100欄左右
你可以想成把一間
堆滿雜物的倉庫重新整理
只留下100個抽屜
每個抽屜代表一個大主題
然後把每個詞丟進最像他的那幾個抽屜裡
這個方法叫做潛在語意分析
英文簡稱LSA
壓完之後發生了一件事
Car跟Automobile這兩個幾乎不會同時出現在一句話裡的詞
第一次在數學上靠在一起了
這是人類第一次真的畫出語意的座標
比後面那個引爆全世界的方法還早了23年
1990年那張表格有個先天的毛病
它是靜態的
語料一變就得整個重算
也學不會新的詞
真正指出要愛條路的人是Yosha Bengio
1003年
他跟同事發表了一篇論文
做法完全不一樣
他們讓一個神經網絡
去做一件很無聊的事
看前面幾個詞
猜下一個詞是什麼
重點在於
這個網絡為了猜得準
必須自己在內部長出一套
對每個詞的理解
那套理解就是一組座標
詞的座標不是他們本來要的東西
是這個訓練過程順手長出來的副產品
這就像一個學生
為了應付考試拼命讀書
考完之後你會發現
他腦子裡多出來的
不是那幾道題目的答案
是一整張學科的地圖
這個想法完全正確
問題出在1003年
那時候的電腦跑這種模型
慢得讓人絕望
磁位表只能開幾萬個
語料只能用一小塊
正確的想法有了
算力還沒到
十年之後
補上那塊算力的人
是一個沒什麼人聽他說話的
年輕研究員
Thomas Mikolov
捷克人
2012年在布爾諾拿到博士
論文題目就是用神經網絡
做語言模型
他進了Google之後跟同事說
磁向量這件事
可以做得又快又好
根據他自己後來的回憶
當時沒有人認真聽
實驗室的注意力
全都在另一篇
他覺得又複雜
又多餘的論文上
他決定不再說服任何人
自己動手寫
他沒有申請重集
也沒有排隊等機器
就用一臺
普通的桌上型電腦
幾個星期之後
結果出來了
他寫的那套程式
從16億個詞的語料裡
學出高品質的詞項量
花了時間不到一天
而Google
內部那個
用好幾臺機器
訓練好幾個星期的模型
被他一臺桌機的結果拉開了一整節
這件事的重點不是他多聰明
他證明的是
這條路之所以走不通
不是想法錯了
是大家一直把它做得太複雜
他把那套程式命名為Word to Vector
字面意思就是把詞變成向量
他到底怎麼學的
做法簡單到你會懷疑他為什麼有效
你拿一句話出來
今天早上我喝了一杯熱咖啡
他把中間那個詞遮起來
問模型
前後這幾個字圍著的空格應該填什麼
或者反過來
給模型一個咖啡
要他猜咖啡旁邊通常會出現哪些詞
整份語調就這樣一句一句滑過去
猜錯就每條一隻座標
猜對就把座標留著
挖過幾十一個詞之後
那些常常被同樣的鄰居圍著的詞
位置自然就被拉到一起了
你發現了嗎
這正是Furz那句話的機器版本
看一個詞跟誰帶在一起
就知道它是什麼意思
Furz是用嘴巴講的
Word to Vector是用幾十億次猜測
把同一件事做成了座標
M. Mikolov真正的功勞
這個猜測的計算量壓到幾滴
低到一臺桌子一天就能跑完
結果這麼好
論文應該一路順風吧
並沒有
2013年1月
他把第一篇Water Vector論文
投到一個叫ICLR的機器學習會議
被拒絕了
這件事最尷尬的地方在於
那一年那個會議的接收率大約是七成
也就是說十篇裡面收七篇
而後來改變整個領域的那一篇
剛好落在被退回來的那三篇裡
Miccolo自己在2023年公開講過這一段
他也提到Google大約在那年8月
批准把程式碼開放出來
等審批的那段時間
他還順手把程式改得更短更快
程式一放出來
事情就不受任何人控制了
全世界的工程師下載訓練
接近自己的系統
詞項量在兩三年之內
變成了自然語言處理的標準配備
至於那篇被拒絕的研究
他的續作在十年後
拿下了New York IPS
2023年的時間考驗獎
這個獎專門頒給
當年沒被看懂
但是經得起時間檢驗的論文
真正讓所有人坐直起來的
是另外一件事
既然每個詞都變成了座標
那座標之間的減法
又代表什麼
研究團隊做的一個實驗
他們拿King這個詞的座標
減掉Man的座標
再加上Woman的座標
然後去看落點附近站著誰
OK
安答是Queen
你把這件事想清楚會有點發毛
沒有人教過這個模型什麼叫性別
他從頭到尾只是在猜下一個詞而已
可是一時一旦變成座標
意識之間的關係就變成了方向
從Man走到Woman的那個方向
跟從King走到Queen的方向
幾乎是同一個
同樣的道理
巴黎剪掉法國
再加上意大利
弱點是羅馬
首都這個關係
在地圖上也是一個方向
這一刻
語義不再只是
誰跟誰比較近
它有了幾何
這也是整段歷史裡
最漂亮的畫面
一個從來沒有人民說過的規則
自己從資料里長得出來
不過我必須跟你講一件
很少被提起的事
因為它才是這個故事
誠實的部分
2020年
一組研究者
在計算語言學期刊上
發表了一篇論文
標題直接寫著
公平比慫恫更好
他們回頭去驗那個著名的等式
發現了一個細節
King-Man-Woman說
李洛點最近的那個座標
其實是King自己
Queen只是第二名
而所有教科書上會給你Queen
是因為標準的工具程式
包含word factor
自己附的那一支
預設就會把輸入用過的那幾個詞
從答案裡排除掉
你可以說這是合理的工程處理
因為問題本來就不是要他回答King
但你也必須承認
那個讓全世界驚呼的示範
是修過圖的
方向確實存在
關係確實被學到了
這些都是真的
可是展示出來的那個乾淨結果
中間隔著一行沒有人提起的城市
科學傳播最難的地方就在這裡
連自己這一邊的神話也得拿去查證
魔法之外
Word to Vector還有一個更根本的限制
而這個限制後來把整個領域推向下一個階段
它給每一個詞一個固定的座標
一輩子就那一個
可是語言不是這樣運作的
英文的bank在river bank也是河岸
bank account也是銀行
中文更明顯
蘋果發表會的蘋果
跟蘋果削皮的蘋果
是兩件完全不同的東西
一個固定座標要同時代表這兩個意思
結果就是它哪一個都不像
只能卡在中間某個很尷尬的位置
就像你在地圖上只能給一家連鎖店標一個點
可是它在城市的東邊跟西邊各有一間分店
你標在中間兩邊的人都找不到
問題到這裡已經很清楚了
一個詞的意思不是它自己決定的
是它這一次出現在哪一句話裡決定的
插表這個做法走到頭了
假髮在2018年出現
一群來自艾倫人工智慧研究院
跟華盛頓大學的研究者
做了一個模型
名字取自芝麻街的角色
他的想法很乾脆
不要再查表了
你要一個詞的座標
就把整句話丟進模型
讓模型從頭到尾讀一遍
再從他的內部狀態
把這個詞的座標取出來
同一個bang在兩句不同話裡
就會拿到兩個不同的座標
這件事的意義很大
座標從一張固定的表
變成一個現場計算的結果
同一年10月
Google發表了Bird
走的是同一條路
但是更徹底
他讓模型在讀句子的時候
隨機遮掉一些詞
逼他從左右兩邊的上下文把答案還原回來
這兩篇論文分別拿下了NAACL2018年跟2019年的最佳論文
NAACL是自然語言處理最主要的學術會議之一
同一個研究方向連續兩年拿下最佳論文
這在學界等於一句話
轉折點就在這裡
不過Bert這種做法有一個很現實的問題
他太慢了
Bert判斷兩句話像不像
必須把兩句話一起位進去讀一遍
讀完才給你一個分數
你手上有一萬個句子
想找出最相似的那一對
就得碼一萬個句子兩兩配對跑幾千萬次
2019年那篇論文算過這個數字
用當時的顯示卡
這件事要花大約65個小時
我也在德國的研究者提出了一個改法
叫Sentence Burt
他們改成先讓模型單獨讀每一句話
各自產生一支座標
之後要比較的時候
只要算座標之間的距離就好
同樣一萬句話
同樣的準確度
時間從65個小時調到大約5秒
這個改動的精神你在生活裡見過
一個神稿人如果每次都要把兩份文件
並排從頭讀一遍
他一天讀不完幾組
但如果他先幫每份文件寫一張摘要卡片
之後直筆卡片
一個下午就能把整項文件排完
從這一刻起
Embedding從一個詞的技術
變成一整段文字的技術
地圖上的居民很快就不只有文字了
2021年
OpenAI發表了一個模型叫CLIP
他同時訓練兩個網路
一個讀圖片
一個讀文字
然後要求他們把真的配在一起的圖片跟說明
放到地圖上幾乎同一個位置
把不成對的推開
他用了網路上4億組圖片
跟說明文字來做這件事
訓練完之後
一張狗的照片
跟a photo of a dog
這句英文
位置靠得非常近
你想想這代表什麼
以圖找字
以字找圖
全部變成同一件事
算距離
你手機相簿
那次搜尋
用的就是這一類技術
你打的那幾個字
跟你的照片
被放進同一張地圖
機器只是找了一下
誰離你最近
順帶一提
這篇論文的作者名單裡
有Iliya Saskiva
2013年
World2Vector的第二篇論文
作者名單裡也有她
同一個人
橫跨了這張地圖的兩個時代
我們的歷史線講到這裡就走完了
接下來我想帶你看
這張地圖今天長在哪些地方
而最常見的那個地方
你每天都在用
它叫RAG
RAG的意思是
先去查資料
再讓AI根據查到的東西回答
所有那些跟你的PDF對話
公司內部知識庫問答的產品
底下都是這一條管線
我們一步一步走一遍
第一步
把文件切成一塊一塊
這個動作叫Chunking
一份三百頁的手冊不能整份丟進去
工程師會把它切成一段一段
像把一本書做成一張一張索引卡
這裡有一個要拿捏的地方
卡片切得太小
每一張都沒頭沒尾
讀了不知道在講什麼
切得太大
一張卡上寫了五個主題
那張卡的座標就會變得很模糊
什麼都像一點
什麼都不夠像
第二步
每一張卡片
各自過一次embedding模型
變成一隻座標
然後全部存進一個
專門存座標的地方
這種資料庫叫向量資料庫
使用者問問題的時候
第三步開始
他打的那一句問題
也要用同一個模型
轉成一隻座標
這裡有一條鐵律
一定要是同一個模型
不同模型畫出來的地圖
座標系是不通用的
就像兩張用不同投影法畫的世界地圖
經緯都不能混著看
第四步
在幾百萬只坐標裡
找處理問題最緊的那幾只
這件事如果老老實實一個一個比
會慢到不能用
所以實務上用的是
近似最近零搜尋
英文簡稱ANN
它的精神不是問遍全城每一個人
而是先問各區的里長
所定對的社區
再往裡面轉
犧牲一點點準確度
換來毫秒級的速度
至於怎麼判斷兩支座標近不近
最常用的方法叫cos相似度
你把兩支座標想成
從原點射出去的兩支箭頭
只看它們的夾角
不管誰比較長
同方向就是最像
垂直就是完全無關
最後一步
撈回來的那幾十段還要再塞一次
這個動作叫re-rank
它會用另一個比較慢
但是比較準的模型
把問題跟每一段並排精讀一次
再打分數
整條線就是海選加面試
Embedding負責海選
Rank負責面試
這條管線聽起來很新
但它其實已經默默運轉很多年了
最好的例子是Spotify
早在2013年
也就是World2Vector出來的同一年
Spotify就開放了一套自己寫的程式庫叫Annoy
做的正是在幾百萬字座標裡快速找出最近的鄰居
他們把每一首歌
每一個使用者
都變成這張地圖上的一個點
你每個星期一收到的那份Discover Weekly播放清單
還有你打開首頁看到的推薦
背後就是這個動作
找出離你最近的那些點
再看看他們在聽什麼
這套東西撐了整整十年
2023年
Spotify官方發表了
新一代的程式庫
叫Voyager
換上更新的索引結構
官方的說法是
速度比舊的快了一個量級
我覺得這件事很值得記一下
你以為embedding是
Chad GPT紅了之後
才冒出來的東西
但你的播放清單
早就用它幫你挑了十年的歌
那為什麼是這幾年
才全面爆發
很大一部分原因是價格
今天你叫OpenAI的
入門款embedding模型
幫你處理100萬個token
token
你就想成模型眼中的
一小段文字
大概是一個字到幾個字
價格是0.02美元
100萬個Token
大概是幾十本小說的量
花了錢連一塊臺幣都不到
這個價格比較同一家公司的模型生成文字
便宜了好幾個數量級
便宜到什麼程度呢
一間公司可以把過去十幾年
所有的文件郵件會議記錄
全部跑一遍變成座標
成本只是一頓午餐
這就是為什麼向量資料庫
在2023年突然變成一整個創投賽道
安空這樣的公司
一年之內就拿到了獨角獸等級的估值
不過這裡有一個很真實的代價要講
你換一代embedding模型
舊的座標就全部作廢
因為地圖重畫了
經緯度對不上
幾千萬份文件重新跑一次
這是每一間公司換模型的時候
都要吞下去的賬單
最後我想給你看一條線
它的走向跟直覺相反
1990年那張硬壓出來的地圖
就百個座標軸
world to vector用了300個
拍子用到700多個
到了今天
主流的商用模型
動輒3000多個座標軸
看起來就是一路往上漲
越大越好
對吧
結果2022年之後風向變了
有人提出一種訓練方法
名字叫Metroshka
就是俄羅斯娃娃
他在訓練的時候就規定
座標前面幾個維度要裝最重要的資訊
越往後越吃藥
你要省錢的時候
直接把後面那一節砍掉就好
今天OpenAR的模型
讓你自己指定要幾維
3000多維砍到256維
儲存成本掉了十幾倍
效果還是贏過上一代的完整版
所以這個領域最後學到的
不是越大越好
是可以伸縮才好
我回頭看1957年
Fairt寫下那句話的時候
他手上連一臺電腦都沒有
他說你要認識一個詞
就看它都跟哪些詞待在一起
60幾年後
這句話變成了一組座標
藏在你每一次搜尋
每一份推薦
還有你相簿裡那張
沒有標籤的海邊日落背後
我自己整理完這條線
最深的感覺是
60幾年來
人類其實只做了一件事
就是把意識這個看不見的東西
一點一點搬到一張
可以計算的地圖上
從一片誰跟誰都一樣遠的沙漠
走到你手機裡
那是不用標籤的搜尋
中間隔著一句話
一臺桌上型電腦
還有一封劇稿信
最後問你一個問題
如果你手上所有的筆記
照片
聊天記錄
全部都變成
這張地圖上的座標
你最想拿它來找什麼
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見